for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy so
what about cells in extra hepatic
tissues or tissues basically outside of
the liver what happens if and when
ammonium ion is freed up in those
tissues what happens is the free
ammonium is attached to glutamate to be
actually turned that glutamate into
glutamine and that glutamine is
transported in the blood to the liver at
least to the liver for the most part
also to the kidney okay now how does
that happen how do we actually attach
that free ammonium ion to glutamate to
produce glutamine let's done by an
enzyme called glutamate or sorry
glutamine synthetase and that enzyme
catalyzes a sous-chef broth does who set
process that we see here so we start off
with glutamate here and we're going to
add ATP and then ADP will fall off and
that phosphate group gets attached right
here to produce the Gama gluts Hammel
phosphate which is sort of the activated
intermediate that can follow up by
having an ammonium ion get attached
kicking off that that phosphate group
and we end up with glutamine right which
of course has two nitrogens on it one
right here in the alpha amino group and
one over here in the amide in the
sidechain now this glutamine can
actually go in the blood to the liver
for the disposal of the NH 4 plus which
is kind of what we're going to see in
the next video because there's another
enzyme involved in that or can go to
other tissues for the incorporation of
the NH 4 plus into to building nitrogen
containing compounds but either way it's
a ghostie to the liver or other tissues
to sort of drop off the NH 4 plus now
this reaction although I've shown the
details up here in this two-step process
is often just shown as one sort of
reaction because this
intermedia the gamma glutes hand will
fall spacious and intermediate and
activated intermediate it's not always
shown so the glutamine synthetase step
is often just shown by having you know
adding the amino group removing the
phosphate and the ATP going to ADP now
the concentration of glutamine in the
blood is a lot higher than it is for
other the concentration of other amino
acids in the blood and the reason why is
because glutamine allows for basically
NH 4 transport NH 4 a NH 4 plus
transport in the blood in a non-toxic
way right we can't just take the NH 4
plus and send it to the Bloods liver
that's not how it works because it's
toxic so glutamine because I can have
two nitrogens on it can basically
efficiently transport nitrogen's in the
blood all over the body and glutamine
actually because of that is a source of
nitrogen in or NH 4 plus specifically in
the anabolism a bunch of a nitrogen and
containing compounds so it's pretty
important in that sense as in terms of
its function as an amino acid as part of
amino acid metabolism okay that's pretty
much it for good means in the taste I
hope that video was helpful thank you
for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying